deplorable conditions residents ripped
off and it's all for money according to
police
metro investigators say more and more
they are discovering unlicensed group
homes
yeah and they describe them brian as
houses with multiple senior citizens and
people with disabilities
in unsafe living conditions the i-team's
vanessa murphy takes a closer look at
one case
and the challenge police have to try to
address the problem
police describe an 82-year-old dying man
on a hospital bed with his oxygen tank
nearby in a corner of a kitchen
according to this arrest report he was
on
outpatient hospice care he said he paid
600 dollars a month
for what was supposed to be his own room
in this house in east
las vegas in court documents an
investigator calls the home
horrific and unsanitary police say 12
dogs lived there along with at least
seven other people
including calvin leslie he's accused of
running the unlicensed
group home and ripping off the dying man
and another senior suffering from
dementia police say leslie put
utility bills in his name and stole
social security money from both men by
keeping and
using their debit cards metro sergeant
james johnson
says an alleged scheme like this one is
all too common
as soon as the unit was created in 2019
we had our first unlicensed group home
in
january so right out the gate we're like
oh this could be a problem
sergeant johnson is on the elder abuse
unit which lieutenant david valenta
oversees
they report finding 36 unlicensed group
homes
over the past two years it's almost
disbelief
that people can do this to each other
that you can take the most vulnerable
and actually exploit them the way they
are police say oftentimes
unlicensed group home operators promise
food
shelter and medical care but instead
supply a crowded home with
dirty and unsafe living conditions court
records obtained by the i-team reveal
leslie is a felon
with a lengthy criminal history in
several states
who had no license to run a group home
or provide
medical care leslie was arrested and
faces charges related to elder abuse and
neglect exploitation and theft but
according to investigators
there is no law in nevada to prosecute
someone specifically for running an
unlicensed group home they'd like to
change that
so we're looking to see the best
resources best solutions we can put
together
so we put forward the best legislative
bill we can
metro is partnering with other agencies
including las vegas fire and rescue
so the collaborative efforts that should
have been going on years ago if not
decades ago
is really coming together now assistant
chief john stevenson says his team
also provides support to victims for
example by trying to find them
new homes the demand is this high the
resources to
deal with is this high while
investigators say they're targeting
unlicensed group homes most group homes
are licensed and have rules and
regulations to follow
we put a link where you can verify
whether a home is legitimate
at eight newsnow dot com vanessa murphy
8 news now the i-team also did two
additional reports on the issue earlier
today they dug deeper into police
investigations and
showed us how adult protective services
is really trying to address this problem
you can find those reports at eight
newsnow dot com